Over the past 40 years, the number of people in the United States who speak a language other than English at home has nearly tripled to 68 million. That's about one in every five Americans. And in many other parts of the world, bilingualism and multilingualism are even more common. In fact, more than half the world's population speaks more than one language. In recent years, scientists have begun to explore what's going on in the brains of people who are bilingual or multilingual. And they found evidence that speaking multiple languages may have cognitive benefits that include improving people's executive function abilities and slowing down the progression of age-related dementia. Researchers are also learning more about how the bilingual brain processes language and how the
在过去的40年里，美国在家中使用非英语语言的人数几乎翻了三倍，达到6800万。这大约占美国总人口的五分之一。在世界其他许多地方，双语和多语现象更为普遍。事实上，全球超过一半的人口会说不止一种语言。近年来，科学家们开始探索双语或多语人士的大脑中发生了什么。他们发现有证据表明，掌握多种语言可能具有认知益处，包括提高人们的执行功能，并减缓与年龄相关的痴呆症的发展。研究人员也在进一步了解双语大脑如何处理语言，以及
languages we speak shape the way we think and perceive the world. So why might speaking multiple languages have such far-reaching benefits? How does the brain process more than one language at a time? How do the languages we speak affect the way we see the world and the decisions we make? And what counts as being bilingual? Are people who are fluent in computer code or even math or music bilingual? And finally, if you're interested in the benefits of learning a new language, is it ever too late to try? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between
我们所说的语言如何塑造我们的思维方式和对世界的感知。那么，为什么掌握多种语言会有如此深远的好处？大脑如何同时处理多种语言？我们所说的语言如何影响我们看待世界的方式和我们所做的决定？什么才算双语者？精通计算机代码、数学甚至音乐的人算双语者吗？最后，如果你对学习一门新语言的好处感兴趣，现在开始尝试是否太晚了？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨
psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Villarica Marion, a professor in the Department of Psychology and Communication Sciences and Disorders at Northwestern University. She's a psychologist and cognitive scientist whose research focuses on bilingualism and multilingualism.
心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是西北大学心理学与传播科学及障碍系教授维拉里卡·马里昂博士。她是一位心理学家和认知科学家，其研究重点是双语和多语现象。
She studies the relationship between language and memory, as well as how people process spoken and written language. Dr. Marion is the author of the recent book, The Power of Language, How the Codes We Use to Think, Speak, and Live, transform our minds. Dr. Marion, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me. It's good to be here. You open your book with an epigraph. To have another language is to possess another soul. Why did you choose that quote? What does it mean to you? I chose that quote because it reflects on what people who speak to or more languages often experience, that when they use
她研究语言与记忆之间的关系，以及人们如何处理口语和书面语言。马里昂博士是近期出版的《语言的力量：我们用来思考、说话和生活的代码如何改变我们的思维》一书的作者。马里昂博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。谢谢您的邀请，很高兴来到这里。您在书的开头引用了一句题词：“拥有另一种语言，就是拥有另一个灵魂。”您为什么选择这句话？它对您意味着什么？我选择这句话是因为它反映了那些说两种或多种语言的人经常有的体验，即当他们使用
their different languages, they become slightly different versions of themselves. With each language bringing to the forefront, different cultural experiences, different memories, different aspects of their identity, different relationships, and in a way serving as a filter through which they see the world and interact with themselves, with others, and with the world at large. Now, you speak multiple languages, including Romanian, Russian, and English. How did your own early experiences of language lead you to the work that you're doing now? Yes, so I grew up in a family that spoke Romanian at home in one of the former Soviet republics where Russian was the official language outside the home. So I went to Russian child care. And, um,
不同的语言时，他们会变成略有不同的自己。每种语言都会将不同的文化体验、不同的记忆、不同的身份侧面、不同的人际关系带到前台，并在某种程度上作为一个过滤器，通过它，他们观察世界，并与自己、他人以及整个世界进行互动。现在，您会说多种语言，包括罗马尼亚语、俄语和英语。您早期的语言经历是如何引导您从事现在的工作的？是的，我成长在一个在家说罗马尼亚语的家庭，而在前苏联加盟共和国，俄语是家庭之外的官方语言。所以我上了俄语托儿所，而且，嗯，
grew up with both Romanian and Russian in parallel. Then later in school, I started to study English, then in college, French, then I've learned some Spanish, that I married into a Dutch family, and ended up really being exposed to a variety of languages, which, as you mentioned, early in your introduction, is very common, not only in Europe, but in many different parts of the world. In countries, pretty much every continent, people often speak to more languages from early childhood and then acquire additional languages often later in life. So it is very common for the human condition to really be a bilingual, multilingual one. When you call someone bilingual,
在成长过程中同时接触罗马尼亚语和俄语。后来在学校里，我开始学习英语，大学时学习法语，之后又学了一些西班牙语，后来我嫁入了一个荷兰家庭，最终真正接触到了各种各样的语言。正如您在开场白中提到的，这在欧洲乃至世界许多地方都非常普遍。在几乎每个大洲的国家，人们通常从童年早期就开始说两种或多种语言，之后在生活中往往还会习得额外的语言。因此，双语或多语状态确实是人类的一种普遍状况。当您称某人为双语者时，
does that mean the person grew up speaking two languages or can you become bilingual later in life by studying another language and becoming fluent? In other words, I'm looking for a definition. You can become bilingual at any age. So you don't have to grow up with two languages to be bilingual. You can learn a second language in childhood and adolescence and adulthood and even in your older age. A bilingual is a person who can use two languages. A multilingual is a person who knows and can use more than two languages. So the definition of bilingualism is broad and it depends you know really who you talk to. But it's the ability to encode our thoughts, our ideas, concepts in more than one symbolic system and then be able to transmit across time and space
这是否意味着此人从小就说两种语言，还是说可以通过后来学习另一种语言并达到流利程度而成为双语者？换句话说，我想找一个定义。你可以在任何年龄成为双语者。所以你不必从小就掌握两种语言才能成为双语者。你可以在童年、青春期、成年甚至老年时期学习第二语言。双语者是指能够使用两种语言的人。多语者是指知道并能使用两种以上语言的人。因此，双语的定义很广泛，这取决于你和谁交谈。但它是一种将我们的思想、想法、概念编码到不止一个符号系统中的能力，然后能够跨越时间和空间
these thoughts, these ideas, and have someone else decode them. So the more symbolic systems you have at your disposal, the more languages you know. What about people who can understand a second language, but they can't actually speak it or they speak a little of it with great difficulty. I'm thinking of this. My mother grew up in an Italian family at a time when you weren't supposed to speak Italian except in the home and they didn't want their kids. to speak Italian, but the kids understood what the parents were saying. Do you get any of the brain benefits of being bilingual if you are in that situation? Yeah, so you are referring to what's known as heritage bilingualism. Bilinguals who grow up in a household where there is a heritage language
传输这些思想和想法，并让其他人解码它们。所以你掌握的符号系统越多，你懂的语言就越多。那么那些能听懂第二语言，但实际上不会说，或者说得很吃力的人呢？我想到这一点是因为我的母亲是在一个意大利裔家庭长大的，当时除了在家里，人们不被允许说意大利语，他们也不想让孩子们说意大利语，但孩子们能听懂父母在说什么。如果你处于那种情况，你还能获得双语带来的大脑益处吗？是的，你指的是所谓的“传承双语”。双语者在家庭中成长，那里有一种传承语言，
that their parents or grandparents or their previous generations of their family spoke that may be different from the dominant language outside the home. And there are a lot of many heritage bilinguals in the United States. The extent of their fluency in the two languages varies, but they do indeed show many of the consequences of knowing two languages that children and who grew up with two languages or people who are fluent in both languages show as well. So it's really the type of language experience that you have that can make your bilingual or multilingual. And there are different kinds of bilinguals and multilinguals. Let's talk for a minute about some of the benefits that you researchers have found by studying
他们的父母、祖父母或前几代家人所说的语言可能与家庭之外的主流语言不同。在美国有很多这样的传承双语者。他们对两种语言的流利程度各不相同，但他们确实表现出了许多掌握两种语言所带来的后果，这些后果与从小就说两种语言的孩子或两种语言都流利的人所表现出的后果是一样的。所以，真正让你成为双语者或多语者的是你所拥有的语言经验类型。双语者和多语者有不同的种类。让我们花点时间谈谈你们研究人员通过研究
people who are bilingual or multilingual. What are the kinds of benefits that they experience in the way that they think, in the way that their brain functions and maybe even is structured? Yeah. So one of the most striking and interesting findings in recent years is that people who use two-omor languages show a delayed onset of Alzheimer's and other types of dementia. They are diagnosed on average four to six years later than monolinguals depending on the study that you are looking at. It seems that knowing two-omal languages
双语或多语人士所发现的一些益处。他们在思维方式、大脑功能甚至大脑结构方面经历了哪些益处？是的。近年来最引人注目和有趣的发现之一是，使用两种或多种语言的人表现出阿尔茨海默病和其他类型痴呆症的发病延迟。根据你所参考的研究，他们被诊断出的时间平均比单语者晚四到六年。看起来掌握两种或多种语言
offer some of those protective benefits against the cognitive decline that's often seen that's sometimes seen with healthy aging and that's regularly seen with dementia. And not only at the individual level, but at the population level, there are now studies that show that countries in which two or more languages are official languages of the country have a lower incidence of dementia than countries where one language is the official language of the country. And there is actually a direct correlation between the number of languages, as spoken in the country in the incidence of Alzheimer. So it's a really interesting new finding showing that the consequences of being bilingual
提供了一些针对认知衰退的保护性益处，这种衰退有时在健康老龄化中可见，而在痴呆症中则经常出现。不仅在个人层面，在人口层面，现在也有研究表明，将两种或多种语言作为官方语言的国家，其痴呆症的发病率低于将一种语言作为官方语言的国家。事实上，一个国家所使用的语言数量与阿尔茨海默病的发病率之间存在直接的相关性。所以这是一个非常有趣的新发现，表明成为双语者或多语者的后果
or multilingual are not only the level of the individual, but also at the level of society. And actually in my book, The Power of Language, I organized the book is structured into two parts. The first one talks about the self and then the second one talks about society and how both are changed by knowing to a moment. languages. In the case of dementia, what seems to be happening is that the constant workouts that our brains receive by having to juggle multiple languages is like an exercise for the brain and has this positive consequences. So one way to describe this is imagine that you have been taking the same bridge or the same road home every day for many years throughout your life.
不仅是在个人层面，而且是在社会层面。实际上，在我的书《语言的力量》中，我将书分为两部分。第一部分谈论自我，第二部分谈论社会，以及两者如何因掌握两种或多种语言而改变。在痴呆症的情况下，似乎发生的情况是，我们的大脑因为必须处理多种语言而不断进行的锻炼，就像是大脑的体操，并产生了这些积极的后果。所以描述这一点的一种方式是，想象一下你多年来每天都走同一座桥或同一条路回家。
You go to work, you come home, you take this road. You go to the store, you go to the pharmacy, wherever you're going, you go back and forth, you always take the same road. And then one day when you way back, you discover that that road has collapsed. If that's the only road that exists to your house, then you are in trouble. You won't be able to reach your destination. But if there are multiple roads that have been built over time, if you know of those roads, roads, then you simply reroute your car and you are able to reach your destination with no problem. In the same way, if there are multiple languages that you've used throughout your life to encode memories, to encode experiences, to learn, to live your life in, you can compensate functionally
你去上班，回家，走这条路。你去商店，去药店，无论去哪里，你来来回回总是走同一条路。然后有一天，当你回家的路上，你发现那条路塌了。如果那是通往你家的唯一道路，那么你就麻烦了。你将无法到达目的地。但如果随着时间的推移已经修建了多条道路，如果你知道那些道路，那么你只需重新规划路线，就能毫无问题地到达目的地。同样，如果你一生中使用了多种语言来编码记忆、编码经验、学习、生活，你就可以在功能上进行补偿，
through using those languages for the anatomical deterioration that your brain experiences. So it's not that the bilingual or multilingual brain doesn't experience deterioration. It does. But people who know normal languages are able to compensate for it functionally and live a health life as if they don't have the same degree of impact for longer. And four to six years might not seem like a lot when you are, I don't know, 20, 18, but when you are older four to six years, is really a big difference
通过使用这些语言来弥补大脑所经历的解剖学上的退化。所以并不是说双语或多语的大脑不会经历退化。它会。但掌握两种或多种语言的人能够从功能上进行补偿，并过上健康的生活，就好像他们受到的影响程度较小，持续时间更长。当你20岁或18岁时，四到六年可能看起来不算什么，但当你年老时，四到六年确实是一个巨大的差异，
and can make a difference from being able to play with your grandchildren or never knowing them. And there is nothing else that we know of, other than perhaps exercise that has as strong of an effect on a protective effect on cognitive decline and Alzheimer's system and dementia as the effect size of bilingualism and multilingualism. So it's a,
这可能决定了你是能和孙辈们一起玩耍，还是根本不认识他们。除了运动之外，我们所知的没有任何其他事物对认知衰退和阿尔茨海默病及痴呆症具有如此强大的保护作用，其效果量与双语和多语现象相当。所以这是一个，
one of the most remarkable recent findings in the field. So exercises up there, but what about some of these other mentally enriching things that we engage in, such as maybe having more years of education or a challenging hobby? You're saying that being multilingual gives you greater cognitive benefits than those things? Those are all good, and you're right that a level of education is a plus. nutrition is a plus, engaging and enriching activities is a plus. All of those things are very good. But based on my review of the literature looking at meta-analysis,
该领域最近最引人注目的发现之一。所以运动名列前茅，但我们参与的其他一些丰富精神的活动呢，比如接受更多的教育或培养一个具有挑战性的爱好？您是说掌握多种语言比这些事情能带来更大的认知益处吗？这些都很好，你说得对，受教育程度是一个加分项。营养是一个加分项，参与丰富的活动也是一个加分项。所有这些事情都非常好。但根据我对文献的综述和元分析，
it seems like that effect sizes our largest for exercise in bilingualism. And what's really interesting about bilingualism and multilingualism is that you don't have to take time out of your life to engage in those activities to see benefits. So, for example, we know that engaging in cognitively enriching benefits, in cognitively enriching activities like Sudoku or word puzzles or math, just any kind of cognitively challenging activity is beneficial for the brain. And it's a good thing to do as we age for our cognitive health. But for all of those, you have to actively take time out of your life.
似乎运动和双语现象的效果量最大。双语和多语现象真正有趣的地方在于，你不需要从生活中抽出时间去参与这些活动就能看到益处。例如，我们知道参与认知丰富的活动，如数独、填字游戏或数学，任何一种具有认知挑战性的活动对大脑都是有益的。随着我们年龄的增长，为了我们的认知健康，这样做是件好事。但对于所有这些，你都必须主动从生活中抽出时间
to do those things, whether it's reading, and of course, reading is wonderful for you, whether it's doing puzzles, that's all great. But with being bilingual and multilingual, you simply go about your life using one language or another, and you are constantly giving your brain a workout, because your brain has to facilitate the language you are using and inhibit the language you're not using and sort of control the languages you're using at any given time. For example, you and I right now are speaking in English, our brains have to control our language. Our brains have to control our output. It would do us little good if I suddenly would switch to Spanish or French or Romanian or Russian. So I have to make sure that I control those. I inhibit those and I facilitate
去做这些事情，无论是阅读——当然，阅读对你非常有益——还是做拼图，这些都很棒。但作为双语或多语者，你只需在生活中使用一种或另一种语言，你就不断地给大脑进行锻炼，因为你的大脑必须促进你正在使用的语言，抑制你没有使用的语言，并以某种方式控制你在任何特定时间使用的语言。例如，你和我现在正在用英语交谈，我们的大脑必须控制我们的语言。我们的大脑必须控制我们的输出。如果我突然切换到西班牙语、法语、罗马尼亚语或俄语，对我们没什么好处。所以我必须确保我控制住它们。我抑制它们，并促进
just English. And you do this all the time, whether you are reading a road sign, you're listening to a movie, a song, you're speaking with someone, you're constantly juggling your many languages. So this constant experience juggling different languages seems to be having an effect on executive function that later translates to benefits beyond just language. And I have to say that this area of research, not the dementia part, but the executive function part is somewhat controversial. Not all studies find benefits of bilingualism on executive function. And sometimes people up in arms about that. I am not up in arms about that and I can tell you why. The reason I'm not up in arms about that is because bilingual experience varies.
仅仅是英语。你一直都在这样做，无论你是阅读路标、听电影、听歌，还是与人交谈，你都在不断地处理你的多种语言。因此，这种处理不同语言的持续经验似乎对执行功能产生了影响，这种影响后来转化为超越语言本身的益处。我必须说，这一研究领域，不是痴呆症部分，而是执行功能部分，在某种程度上是有争议的。并非所有的研究都发现双语对执行功能有益。有时人们对此争论不休。我并不争论，我可以告诉你原因。我之所以不争论，是因为双语经验各不相同。
There are different kinds of bilingualism. Executive function is an umbrella term that includes multiple components. So I think asking the question in this absolute ways, does bilingualism benefit executive function or more? This black or white approach is not the right way to look at things. A better question would be to ask what aspect, what kinds of language experience influence what kind of executive function and under what circumstance? It's sort of like thinking about exercise. I think universally, everyone knows that exercise is good for you. We agree that exercise is good for your health and for aging.
双语有不同的种类。执行功能是一个涵盖多个组成部分的统称。所以我认为以这种绝对的方式提出问题——双语是否对执行功能有益，或者更多？这种非黑即白的做法不是看待事物的正确方式。一个更好的问题是问：什么样的语言经验在什么情况下影响什么样的执行功能？这有点像思考运动。我认为普遍来说，每个人都知道运动对你有好处。我们同意运动对你的健康和衰老有益。
But it's not like every single type of exercise you do will benefit every single type of your health under every single kind of amounts and duration. And there are just so many other variables. Some things benefit. Some variables, others benefit other variables. So taking this absolute black and white approach is really important. not a good way to do science. I know that we all like simplified yes, no answers, but it's a much more nuanced, nuanced, complicated issue. I want to talk for a minute about what goes on in the brains of people who know multiple languages. Are all of the languages, you know, always active,
但并不是说你做的每一种运动都会在每一种数量和持续时间下对你的每一种健康状况都有益。还有很多其他的变量。有些事情有益于某些变量，另一些则有益于其他变量。所以采取这种绝对的非黑即白的做法确实不是做科学的好方法。我知道我们都喜欢简化的“是”或“否”的答案，但这实际上是一个更加微妙、复杂的问题。我想花点时间谈谈掌握多种语言的人的大脑中发生了什么。你所知道的所有语言是否一直处于活跃状态，
or is your brain shutting off and sectioning things so that you know that we're speaking English right now? You're not going to slip into Romanian by accident. Yeah, we used to think, that people switch between languages. There was this language switch hypothesis where there was the belief that when you use one language, you're using it, then you're done with it, you switch it off, you switch the other one on, you use that other language.
还是你的大脑在关闭和划分事物，以便你知道我们现在正在说英语？你不会不小心滑入罗马尼亚语。是的，我们过去认为人们会在语言之间切换。存在一种“语言切换假说”，即人们相信当你使用一种语言时，你在使用它，然后你用完了，你把它关掉，你打开另一种语言，你使用那另一种语言。
And there's also the belief that different languages are represented in different parts of the brain. So you have like a place for English, a place for fringe, a place for Hebrew, a place for Arabic, whatever language you are using. We now know that's not the case. We know that language is distributed throughout multiple areas of the brain. It's a network.
人们还相信不同的语言在大脑的不同部位有表征。所以你就像有一个英语区、一个法语区、一个希伯来语区、一个阿拉伯语区，无论你正在使用什么语言。我们现在知道事实并非如此。我们知道语言分布在大脑的多个区域。它是一个网络。
And we also know that we don't ever really switch off our languages. They are constantly co-activated and running in parallel. So our brain is this very impressive superorganisms that processes information in parallel at all times from multiple modalities. and we know this through multiple lines of research, including research that uses eye tracking that shows that people who speak multiple languages, when they hear a word in one language, they often make eye movements to objects in their visual display
我们也知道我们从来没有真正关闭过我们的语言。它们不断地被共同激活并并行运行。所以我们的大脑是一个非常令人印象深刻的超级有机体，它始终在并行处理来自多种模态的信息。我们通过多条研究路线了解这一点，包括使用眼动追踪的研究，该研究表明，说多种语言的人，当他们听到一种语言中的一个词时，他们经常会向视觉显示器中的物体移动视线，
in their visual scene that sounds similar in another language. So, for example, if you are an English speaker, and I sit you in front of a bunch of objects on the desk, and I tell you to pick up a marker while recording your eye movements, as you pick up the marker, you will often make eye movements to other objects like marbles, for example, that start with the same word onset, like marker and marbles. But if you speak Spanish, you'll make eye movements to other objects that start with the same onset in your language like a butterfly. The Spanish word for butterfly is mariposa. If you speak Russian, you may make eye movements or you do make eye movements.
在他们的视觉场景中，这些物体在另一种语言中听起来很相似。例如，如果你是一个英语使用者，我让你坐在桌子前的一堆物体前，我让你拿起一个记号笔（marker），同时记录你的眼球运动，当你拿起记号笔时，你经常会向其他物体移动视线，比如弹珠（marbles），因为它们以相同的词首开始，比如marker和marbles。但如果你说西班牙语，你会向其他以你语言中相同词首开始的物体移动视线，比如蝴蝶（butterfly）。西班牙语中蝴蝶是mariposa。如果你说俄语，你可能会向邮票移动视线，或者你确实会向邮票移动视线，
movements to a stamp because the Russian word for stamp is marker. So as you hear, marker, you make eye movements to a stamp. So people who speak different languages make eye movements towards different objects as they hear language, different objects in their display, in their visual scene, attract their attention. And we are now even finding that they remember what they had seen differently depending on the language as they speak. So if you ask a Russian speaker, are much more likely to remember that there was a stamp on that desk when they were looking for a marker than an English monolingual speaker. And the Spanish speaker is more likely to remember that, you know, they saw a butterfly flying around
因为俄语中邮票是marker。所以当你听到marker时，你会向邮票移动视线。因此，说不同语言的人在听到语言时会向不同的物体移动视线，他们视觉场景中不同的物体会吸引他们的注意力。我们现在甚至发现，他们根据所说的语言，对所见事物的记忆也不同。所以如果你问一个俄语使用者，当他们在寻找记号笔时，他们更有可能记得桌子上有一枚邮票，而不是英语单语使用者。而西班牙语使用者更有可能记得，你知道，当他们在寻找记号笔时，他们看到了一只蝴蝶在飞，
when they were looking for a marker than if you don't speak Spanish. It's really interesting because it shows us that the languages we speak influence what we see, our perception of the world around us, our perception of reality and influences what we remember later when we think about our environment, so think back to experiences we've had. So language is this very powerful experience that we filter our world through and our lives through. If you grow up in a bilingual household, at what point do you realize that there are two different languages being spoken instead of one big language that encompasses both?
而不是如果你不说西班牙语的话。这真的很有趣，因为它向我们展示了我们所说的语言影响我们所看到的东西、我们对周围世界的感知、我们对现实的感知，并影响我们以后在思考环境时所记住的内容，所以回想一下我们所经历的体验。因此，语言是一种非常强大的体验，我们通过它来过滤我们的世界和我们的生活。如果你在一个双语家庭中长大，你在什么时候意识到有两种不同的语言在被说，而不是一种包含两者的单一的大语言？
That's a good question, because it taps into what's. known as metalinguistic ability. Mental linguistic ability is the ability to reason about language abstractly. And we all as adults develop it eventually. So adults know that you can call something, but by any word you want, and it doesn't change what this word is, I might have a pan, and I might call it a pan or a ruchka or a stiloh, however I might call it, and it doesn't change it. But bilingual kids develop this ability to reason about objects and their names in this abstract ways earlier than monolingual kids.
这是一个好问题，因为它触及了所谓的“元语言能力”。元语言能力是抽象地推理语言的能力。我们所有成年人最终都会发展出这种能力。所以成年人知道你可以随心所欲地用任何词来称呼某物，这不会改变这个词是什么，我可能有一个平底锅（pan），我可能叫它pan，或者ruchka，或者stiloh，无论我怎么叫它，它都不会改变它。但双语孩子比单语孩子更早地发展出这种以抽象方式推理物体及其名称的能力。
At an early age, they understand that the world and the words we used to refer to the world are not one and the same, that you can change the labels and it doesn't change the object. So this is really a foundational, skillful cognitive development, being able to reason abstractly about our, environment and the labels we used to refer to it. In your book, you write about how for people who are bilingual, the experience of speaking in their native versus their non-native language may be quite different. For example, people may make different moral decisions or access different memories when they're talking in their native versus their non-native language. Can you talk about that? What are the connections among language, memory, and emotion that are all at play? This is a really,
在很小的时候，他们就明白世界和我们用来指代世界的词并不是一回事，你可以改变标签，而不会改变物体。所以这确实是一个基础性的、熟练的认知发展，能够抽象地推理我们的环境以及我们用来指代它的标签。在您的书中，您写到对于双语者来说，用母语和非母语说话的体验可能大不相同。例如，人们在用母语和非母语交谈时，可能会做出不同的道德决定或获取不同的记忆。您能谈谈这个吗？语言、记忆和情感之间有什么联系？这是一个非常
reach topic because it does make a big difference in our decision making and the emotions we feel in how we think about our identity and how we interact with others, depending on which language we are speaking at any given time. There is some evidence suggesting that the native language tends to be a more emotional language, tends to be tied to emotions more closely, whereas the second language often can be a more logical language or lead to people making decisions that are more logical and utilitarian. So in one of this areas of research, scientists were asking bilinguals to make moral decisions in either they are native language or they are second language. And I'll give you an example. You may have heard of the very famous trolley dilemma. And there are different
丰富的话题，因为它确实在我们的决策、我们感受到的情感、我们如何思考自己的身份以及我们如何与他人互动方面产生了很大的影响，这取决于我们在任何特定时间正在说哪种语言。有一些证据表明，母语往往是一种更具情感的语言，往往与情感联系得更紧密，而第二语言往往可以是一种更逻辑的语言，或者导致人们做出更符合逻辑和功利主义的决定。因此，在这些研究领域之一中，科学家们要求双语者用他们的母语或第二语言做出道德决定。我给你举个例子。你可能听说过非常著名的“电车难题”。并且有不同的
versions of it, but in this particular version of the trolley dilemma, a trolley is coming down the tracks, and there are five workers working on the tracks, and this trolley is about to run over them and kill them, and you are standing on the footbridge above those tracks next to a large person with a large backpack, and if you push the person off the footbridge, the person will die, but that will stop the trolley and will save the lives of these five people. So the question is, is it permissible to sacrifice the life of one person to save the lives of five people? How would you answer that? I hate that dilemma.
版本，但在电车难题的这个特定版本中，一辆电车正沿着轨道驶来，有五名工人在轨道上工作，这辆电车即将碾过他们并杀死他们，而你正站在轨道上方的人行天桥上，旁边有一个背着大背包的大个子，如果你把那个人推下人行天桥，那个人会死，但这会阻止电车并挽救这五人的生命。所以问题是，牺牲一个人的生命来挽救五个人的生命是可以接受的吗？你会怎么回答？我讨厌那个难题。
I don't know what I would do. I think I would not be able to push somebody off a bridge. I hate the dilemma too. And I know what you mean. And your answer is being it. It really just depends. You can change. A lot of people would say, yeah, I can see how it makes more sense to sacrifice one person for five, but I would never.
我不知道我会怎么做。我想我无法把某人推下桥。我也讨厌这个难题。我知道你的意思。你的回答是……这真的取决于情况。你可以改变。很多人会说，是的，我能看出牺牲一个人换取五个人更有道理，但我永远不会
push a person off the bridge or kill a person. Some people would be more likely to do it if all they have to do is push a button versus push a person. And then it depends if it's five people versus 5,000 people. There are so many versions of this problem. But interestingly, it seems that if you ask bilinguals to make this decision in their native language versus their second language, you see differences in how they answer. They are much more likely to be guided by what's known as Duonton. value, so it's inherently morally right or wrong in their native language and say that they are
把人推下桥或杀人。有些人如果只需要按一个按钮而不是推一个人，就更有可能这样做。然后这取决于它是五个人还是5000个人。这个问题有太多的版本。但有趣的是，如果要求双语者用他们的母语和第二语言做出这个决定，你会看到他们回答方式的差异。他们更有可能受到所谓的“义务论”价值的引导，即在他们的母语中，它本质上是道德上对或错的，并说他们
less likely to sacrifice the life, to kill one person, to sacrifice the life of one person for five when they're speaking their native language versus when they're speaking their second language. When they're speaking their second language, they are more likely to make a utilitarian decision and decide that you go with a decision that has the greater good. So this is one set of experiments, but people have looked at the likelihood of cheating, at medical decisions, at all sorts of decisions. And they are finding that bilingual tend to make different decisions in one language versus another. And it does seem that the first language just tends to be more closely tied to emotions.
在说母语时，比在说第二语言时，更不可能牺牲生命，即杀一个人来牺牲一个人的生命以换取五个人。当他们说第二语言时，他们更有可能做出功利主义的决定，并决定你选择那个能带来最大利益的决定。所以这是一组实验，但人们研究了作弊的可能性、医疗决定、各种各样的决定。他们发现双语者倾向于在一种语言和另一种语言中做出不同的决定。而且第一语言确实往往与情感联系得更紧密。
And I think many individuals who speak to homo languages often experience at themselves, that they feel a different reaction on someone says, I love you to them in their native language. Or when they say themselves in their native language versus their second language. So that's a tip out there for your listeners who may be in the relationships with bilinguals or multilinguals, to learn some of these key phrases, emotional phrases, in the native language of a person you are in a relationship with to help build a deeper connection. And it's also curse words. People where bilingual differ in their likelihood of being able to.
我认为许多说两种或多种语言的人经常自己体验到这一点，当有人用他们的母语对他们说“我爱你”时，他们会感受到不同的反应。或者当他们用母语而不是第二语言对自己说时。所以这对你们的听众来说是一个小贴士，那些可能与双语者或多语者有关系的人，去学习一些关键短语，情感短语，用你所处关系中那个人的母语，以帮助建立更深层的联系。还有脏话。双语者在他们能够
curse or how worked up they get when they hear curse words in their native language versus second language. Many bilinguals, myself included, will tell you that they could never curse in certain, you know, powerful in their native language and have no problem doing that in their second, third, fourth language where you don't have just such strong connections and emotional reactions. So there is this relationship between the language you speak and how you feel, what you remember, the emotion. It's just, we could talk about this for so long because there is just so much interesting research on this topic. And I go into a lot of it in the book,
咒骂的可能性方面，或者当他们听到母语中的脏话与第二语言中的脏话时，他们的激动程度是不同的。许多双语者，包括我自己，会告诉你，他们永远无法用母语说出某些，你知道，强有力的词，而在他们的第二、第三、第四语言中却毫无问题，因为你没有那么强烈的联系和情感反应。所以你所说的语言和你感受到的、你记住的、情感之间存在这种关系。这只是，我们可以谈论这个话题很久，因为关于这个话题有太多有趣的研究。我在书中深入探讨了很多，
but I'm happy to talk about some of the examples here. I want to ask something a little bit out of left field maybe. We did a podcast not that long ago about people who can speak dozens of languages. And I'm wondering in all the research you have done, is there a limit to the number of languages that a human brain can learn? Not that we know of. And I think this is one of the reasons why I'm so interested in multilingualism. At the core of it, I'm interested in language and thought, language and mind, how closely related language and thought are, what does language learning tell us about learning in general? Because there does seem to be a relationship between, you know, with each new language you learn, it becomes easier
但我很高兴在这里谈论一些例子。我想问一个可能有点出乎意料的问题。我们不久前做了一个关于能说几十种语言的人的播客。我想知道在您所做的所有研究中，人类大脑能学习的语言数量有限制吗？据我们所知没有。我认为这就是我为什么对多语现象如此感兴趣的原因之一。其核心是，我对语言和思想、语言和心灵感兴趣，语言和思想联系得多么紧密，语言学习告诉我们关于学习的什么？因为每学习一门新语言，似乎确实存在一种关系，即它变得更容易
to learn additional language. So it's this virtual cycle. The more you learn, the easier it becomes to learn more things in languages. So there are indeed multilinguals who speak two, six, 20, And there have been claims of over 100 languages. And it, of course, also depends on what you define as a language and what you define as fluency. But the human mind seems to be able to learn languages at infinitum, really. And it's really interesting to compare artificial intelligence and human intelligence and use multilingualism as a way to study. the human potential.
去学习额外的语言。所以这是一个良性循环。你学得越多，学习更多语言的事情就变得越容易。所以确实有多语者会说两种、六种、20种语言。甚至有声称会说超过100种语言的。当然，这也取决于你如何定义语言以及你如何定义流利度。但人类的心灵似乎能够无限地学习语言。将人工智能和人类智能进行比较，并利用多语现象作为研究人类潜能的一种方式，这真的很有趣。
What is language, if I can ask that? How do you define it? Is computer code language? Is math language? Is music language? I'm glad you asked it because I think most people use a definitional language in a somewhat narrower sense than I tend to think about it. So usually when most people, when they think about language, they think about natural
如果我可以问的话，什么是语言？您如何定义它？计算机代码是语言吗？数学是语言吗？音乐是语言吗？我很高兴你问这个问题，因为我认为大多数人对语言的定义比我倾向于思考的要狭窄一些。所以通常当大多数人想到语言时，他们想到的是自然
languages like English or Spanish or French or Hindi, a language that a group of people speaks and communicates and a sign language. If we broaden the definition of language to use it to refer to a symbolic system. So language is something that uses symbols to communicate information. then we can go beyond this natural human languages. And it is an apt definition because as we mentioned earlier, what languages do is they use symbols, words, or notations, to encode a thought and idea, a concept transmitted over space and time
语言，如英语、西班牙语、法语或印地语，一种一群人说并交流的语言，以及手语。如果我们拓宽语言的定义，用它来指代一个符号系统。所以语言是使用符号来交流信息的某种东西。那么我们就可以超越这种人类自然语言。这是一个恰当的定义，因为正如我们之前提到的，语言所做的是使用符号、词语或符号来编码一个思想、一个想法、一个概念，跨越空间和时间传输
for someone at the other end or something at the other end to decode it. And if we use that broad definition, that not just natural languages, they're not just sign languages, which are also natural languages, but also computer languages, artificial languages, math, music can also be conceived of as symbolic systems, as languages, and many will tell you that math is a language.
给另一端的人或另一端的某物去解码它。如果我们使用那个广泛的定义，即不仅仅是自然语言，不仅仅是手语（它们也是自然语言），而且计算机语言、人工语言、数学、音乐也可以被构想为符号系统，作为语言，许多人会告诉你数学就是一种语言。
That's one of the most powerful languages out there. Math is the queen of sciences that allows us to encode really complex, ideas that has allowed humanity to make discoveries and build things that we wouldn't be able to do without math. So if we broaden the definition of language to symbolic systems, then most of our minds, even if we only speak one natural language, human natural language, have multiple symbolic systems at our disposal because we can read math and use math. Perhaps we can read music.
那是现存最强大的语言之一。数学是科学的皇后，它允许我们编码非常复杂的思想，这使人类能够做出发现并建造我们没有数学就无法做到的事情。所以如果我们把语言的定义拓宽到符号系统，那么我们大多数人的大脑，即使我们只说一种人类自然语言，我们也可以使用多种符号系统，因为我们可以阅读数学并使用数学。也许我们可以阅读音乐。
And each of those symbolic systems changes the way we think. If you have math and you can reason about very big numbers that we couldn't reason about centuries ago, or you have very small numbers again, you can use math and language to now talk about things that I cannot see. and create mental concepts that you would not be able to create otherwise. So language is key to scientific discovery, to thought, to technology, to science, to human advancement. It's one of the most powerful tools we have at our disposal. We all know that it's easy or easier for kids to pick up a language compared to, adults, but can a person learn a language fluently at any age?
而每一个符号系统都会改变我们的思维方式。如果你有数学，你就可以推理几个世纪前我们无法推理的非常大的数字，或者你又有非常小的数字，你现在可以使用数学和语言来谈论我看不见的事物，并创造出你否则无法创造的心理概念。因此，语言是科学发现、思想、技术、科学、人类进步的关键。它是我们掌握的最强大的工具之一。我们都知道孩子比成年人更容易习得语言，但一个人可以在任何年龄流利地学习一门语言吗？
We used to think that there is this critical age period. And if you miss that critical age period, too bad. You won't be able to learn a language and you won't be able to learn a second or third language. That turns out not to be the case. You can learn a second language and you can or third or multiple languages and you can learn them to fluency at any age. Now, you may have an accent if you learn your second or third language later in life after puberty, after your articulatory system is set. Not always, some people don't have accents, but many do. You can hear me speak with an accent in English, even though I would consider myself fluent in English. I do have an accent because I learned English later in life. But I'm fluent in it,
我们过去认为存在一个关键年龄期。如果你错过了那个关键年龄期，太糟糕了。你将无法学习一门语言，你将无法学习第二或第三语言。事实证明并非如此。你可以在任何年龄学习第二语言，或者第三或多种语言，并且你可以流利地学习它们。现在，如果你在青春期之后，在你的发音系统定型之后，在以后的生活中学习你的第二或第三语言，你可能会有口音。并不总是这样，有些人没有口音，但很多人有。你可以听到我用英语说话带有口音，尽管我会认为自己英语流利。我确实有口音，因为我是在以后的生活中学习英语的。但我很流利，
and you can learn a language to fluency at any age. But even if you don't learn a language to fluency, I would almost say it helps to remove that pressure of yourself and say, well, I can't be fluent. I will always have an accent. I'll never be fluent in another language, so maybe I shouldn't even bother. I think that's the wrong approach. You can see a lot of the consequences and benefits of learning another language, even without being fluent. And most of all, it can actually improve your quality of life in many different ways, depending on how you choose to learn another language.
你可以在任何年龄流利地学习一门语言。但即使你没有流利地学习一门语言，我几乎会说，这有助于消除你自己的那种压力，说：“好吧，我不可能流利。我永远会有口音。我永远不会精通另一种语言，所以也许我甚至不应该费心。”我认为这是错误的方法。即使不流利，你也能看到学习另一种语言的许多后果和益处。最重要的是，它实际上可以通过多种不同的方式提高你的生活质量，这取决于你选择如何学习另一种语言。
But if you choose to learn another language by engaging in activities that you enjoy, that bring you pleasure and enjoy and enrich your life, and you find a way to learn another language that makes you happy, be it by exchanging language lessons with another person. And we know that social interaction is so beneficial for mental health, physical health, has a lot of positive consequences. Or by immersion, by traveling and living in another, not a country and you enjoy that, then the quality of your life will be improved by that.
但如果你选择通过参与你喜欢的、给你带来快乐和享受并丰富你生活的活动来学习另一种语言，并且你找到了一种让你快乐的学习另一种语言的方法，无论是通过与他人交换语言课程——我们知道社交互动对心理健康、身体健康非常有益，有很多积极的后果——还是通过沉浸式学习，通过旅行和生活在另一个国家，而你享受这一点，那么你的生活质量就会因此得到改善。
Or maybe you enjoy learning it using apps. And many of the apps right now capitalize on the knowledge we have from neuroscience by having this reward circuit and the brain activated all the serotonin. And you play this game and you get a reward of some sort where it's a badge or sound and you move through levels. and you enjoy doing that. So whatever it is, maybe you enjoy listening to music in another language or watching a movie in another language.
或者也许你喜欢使用应用程序来学习它。现在许多应用程序利用了我们从神经科学中获得的知识，通过激活大脑中的这个奖励回路和所有的血清素。你玩这个游戏，你得到某种奖励，无论是徽章还是声音，你通过关卡。你喜欢这样做。所以无论是什么，也许你喜欢听另一种语言的音乐或看另一种语言的电影。
So there are so many reasons to learn another language that may make your life more enjoyable and better that even if you don't become fluent is worthwhile. I want to talk for a minute about an op-ed that you wrote that was published in the Washington Post not long ago that talked about how artificial intelligence may decrease language diversity and multilingualism in the future. Why do you believe that? So I will pull back by saying that most artificial intelligence that is now making the news as it is so much,
学习另一种语言有许多理由，这些理由能让你的生活更愉快、更美好，即使你无法达到流利程度，也是值得的。我想花点时间谈谈你不久前在《华盛顿邮报》上发表的一篇评论文章，文中谈到了人工智能在未来可能会减少语言多样性和多语现象。你为什么这么认为？我想先退一步说，现在大多数登上新闻的人工智能，因为它们太……
relies what's known as large language models. And these large language models follow the same principles that linguists and psycholinguists, psychologists of language, have been studying for decades. I don't think that many people anticipated that the advancement of this large language models will happen as fast as it has and that they will be able to do as much as they can right now already
依赖于所谓的“大语言模型”。这些大语言模型遵循着语言学家和心理语言学家（语言心理学家）几十年来一直在研究的相同原则。我认为很多人并没有预料到这些大语言模型的发展速度会如此之快，而且它们现在已经能够完成这么多事情了。
based on essentially learning and using statistical problems. capabilities and their input at the base. But now that AI is there and it's developing so rapidly and we have this evolution of AI, evolution of knowledge, at a very rapid pace faster than previous generations, it's everyone's guess what will happen next. And people vary in the predictions they make. and their predictions are informed based on their knowledge. If you're a computer scientist, if you're a learning theorist, I'm a psycholinguist.
本质上是基于学习和使用统计问题。它们的能力和输入是基础。但现在人工智能已经出现，并且发展如此迅速，我们正经历着人工智能的进化、知识的进化，其速度比前几代人快得多，接下来会发生什么，谁也说不准。人们的预测各不相同，而他们的预测是基于各自的知识。如果你是计算机科学家，如果你是学习理论家，而我是心理语言学家。
So my predictions are based on what I know about language. And what I will say to that is that our initial predictions, my initial expectation and reaction would be to think that having this LLAMs will be beneficial to language diversity because we think, well, now we can use online translation tools. It can immediately translate text. It can translate language input. Here's my phone. And I can speak into it and will immediately translate when I'm traveling into the language of my listener.
所以我的预测是基于我对语言的了解。对此我想说的是，我们最初的预测，我最初的期望和反应会认为拥有这些大语言模型（LLM）将有利于语言多样性，因为我们想，好吧，现在我们可以使用在线翻译工具了。它可以立即翻译文本。它可以翻译语言输入。这是我的手机。我对着它说话，当我旅行时，它会立即翻译成听者的语言。
So these are all wonderful things and certainly great benefits. You can also now document, record and save many languages that are dying. So the initial thought is that it will be benjamin. And we do have those beneficial components. But I think long term, my prognosis for the diversity of natural languages as a result of AI is grim. And here's why. There are more than 7,000 languages spoken in the world today. We lose a few every year.
所以这些都是美妙的事情，当然也是巨大的好处。你现在还可以记录、保存许多正在消亡的语言。所以最初的想法是它将是有益的。我们确实拥有这些有益的成分。但我认为从长远来看，由于人工智能的影响，我对自然语言多样性的预测是严峻的。原因如下：当今世界上有超过7000种语言。我们每年都会失去几种。
In theory, you could have LLMs, you could have large languages. models based on all of these 7,000 plus natural languages. However, the way LLM's work is they learn based on the digital footprint that the language has online. So the more information, the larger the database that exists online, the better those language models will be. And we do have a huge linguistic footprint in English, in Mandarin, in French, in several languages.
理论上，你可以拥有大语言模型，你可以拥有基于所有这7000多种自然语言的大语言模型。然而，大语言模型的工作方式是基于该语言在网上的数字足迹进行学习。因此，信息越多，在线存在的数据库越大，这些语言模型就会越好。我们确实在英语、普通话、法语和几种语言中拥有巨大的语言足迹。
So those models learn on a much large. larger input and therefore they become better than large language models that learn on a much more limited input. And predictions vary on how many LLMs are likely to become really powerful. Some conservative estimates are at around 20, but even if we broaden it from 20 to let's say 200 or 2000, it's not realistic to think 2,000. but that's still more than 7,000 plus. So most likely only a very small, relatively to the 7,000 plus languages will have a large enough digital footprint
因此，这些模型在更大规模的输入上进行学习，因此它们变得比在更有限的输入上学习的大语言模型更好。关于有多少大语言模型可能变得真正强大，预测各不相同。一些保守的估计在20个左右，但即使我们将范围从20扩大到比如200或2000，认为有2000个是不现实的，但这仍然超过了7000多种。所以很可能只有极少数（相对于7000多种语言而言）拥有足够大的数字足迹，
to result in very good, strong LLM's language models. And you can think of this almost as an invasive species that then drives out the smaller languages. And of course, we're not talking about, about tomorrow or a year from now, we are talking about a few generations, but, and this is, and some, some might say much less than a few generations. It remains to be seen because human nature is such that we will always want to use the best, the strongest, so we'll always want to use the best model out there. So eventually a few models will win out. So if we take it, if we push this
从而产生非常优秀、强大的大语言模型。你可以把这几乎看作是一种入侵物种，然后驱逐了较小的语言。当然，我们不是在谈论明天或一年后，我们是在谈论几代人的时间，但是，有些人可能会说远不到几代人的时间。这还有待观察，因为人性使然，我们总是想使用最好的、最强大的，所以我们总是想使用现有的最好的模型。因此，最终少数几个模型会胜出。所以如果我们把这个论点推得更远，
argument really further, almost to the like a science fiction film, direction, you can imagine a situation where a lot of the small languages are disappearing at a much faster pace. And if language and thought are indeed interconnected with this many languages dying out, we lose some diversity of thought. We use the cultures, the concepts, the differences in the way people think as a result of these dying languages. So we will simultaneously potentially have two competing things happening at the same time.
几乎推向科幻电影的方向，你可以想象一种情况，许多小语言正在以快得多的速度消失。如果语言和思想确实是相互关联的，随着这么多语言的消亡，我们失去了一些思想的多样性。由于这些消亡的语言，我们失去了文化、概念以及人们思考方式的差异。因此，我们将同时可能有两个相互竞争的事情同时发生。
Diversity of languages, natural languages disappearing, diversity of human thought disappearing, maybe having more uniform thinking is a result of only several large LLMs. While at the same time as the decreased diversity of languages and thought, the artificial languages and artificial intelligence continues to evolve and becomes stronger. And that's not a great scenario to think about for us humans. Now, we don't know what will happen. Things can go very different ways right now. And just this past week, very recently the European Union started putting some guidelines in place on artificial intelligence.
自然语言的多样性正在消失，人类思想的多样性正在消失，也许由于只有几个大型大语言模型，思维变得更加统一。与此同时，随着语言和思想多样性的减少，人工语言和人工智能继续进化并变得更强大。对于我们人类来说，这不是一个值得思考的好场景。现在，我们不知道会发生什么。事情现在可以向非常不同的方向发展。就在过去一周，最近欧盟开始对人工智能实施一些指导方针。
I'm sure most other countries will follow, but it's very difficult, if not impossible, to regulate AI in this kind of research. It doesn't take a lot to have a rotation, or an individual group of individuals to really not want to follow those regulations. So we are on the precipice of big changes in the evolution of knowledge. And I think the psychology of language is likely to play an important role. It almost makes me think of the movie arrival on how important the ability to communicate is for humanity. One last question to wrap up. What are the big questions you're looking at now? What would you like to be able to answer in the next six months or a year?
我相信大多数其他国家也会效仿，但在这种研究中监管人工智能是非常困难的，如果不是不可能的话。不需要太多努力就能有一个轮换，或者一群人真的不想遵守这些规定。所以我们正处于知识进化巨大变革的边缘。我认为语言心理学可能会发挥重要作用。这几乎让我想起了电影《降临》，关于交流能力对人类有多重要。最后一个问题来总结一下。你现在关注的重大问题是什么？你希望在未来六个月或一年内能够回答什么？
We have about a dozen experiments in the lab right now. So for the past more than 20 years, I've been looking at coactivation and parallel processing of languages and bilinguals and multilinguals. And now I'm looking at the consequences of parallel processing for higher level cognition, for higher level cognitive processes like memory, like creativity, like decision making, like semantic organization. So does the fact that our mind processes multiple languages and parallel changes, um, higher level cognition. So I just mentioned the memory study that was just published in science advances this year showing that people who speak different languages remember different things. So now we are looking at the consequences for creativity, decision making. We're also looking at the relationship between form and meaning. So is it completely arbitrary, the form of words and
我们实验室目前有大约十几个实验。在过去的20多年里，我一直在研究双语者和多语者的语言共激活和平行处理。现在我正在研究平行处理对更高级认知的影响，对于更高级的认知过程，如记忆、创造力、决策制定、语义组织。那么，我们的大脑同时处理多种语言这一事实是否会改变更高级的认知？所以我刚才提到了今年发表在《科学进展》上的记忆研究，表明说不同语言的人会记住不同的事情。所以现在我们正在研究对创造力、决策制定的影响。我们也在研究形式与意义之间的关系。那么，词汇的形式与它们所承载的意义之间是完全任意的吗？
the meaning they carry, which tells us about the relationship between language and thought. And this is another question that has been around for centuries. We're looking at, we have a study right now on parent children and parents and children in different countries who are bilingual. And we are finding that parents and children, toddlers, young children, four-year-olds and their moms interact with each other differently depending upon which language they speak. So as early as a preschool age. Children interact differently with their caregivers and the caregivers interact differently with the children depending on the languages that they speak. So we have multiple projects in the lab. We're looking at emotion processing. We're looking at perception of truth
这告诉我们语言与思想之间的关系。这是另一个存在了几个世纪的问题。我们正在研究，我们目前有一项关于不同国家双语父母和孩子的研究。我们发现，父母和孩子、幼儿、年幼的孩子、四岁的孩子和他们的妈妈之间的互动方式取决于他们说哪种语言。所以早在学龄前。孩子们与照顾者互动的方式不同，照顾者与孩子互动的方式也不同，这取决于他们说的语言。所以我们在实验室里有多个项目。我们正在研究情绪处理。我们正在研究对真相的感知
and susceptibility to misinformation across languages. We have so much information across languages. We have so many interesting projects and there is enough work for lifetime, many more lifetimes. I think it's a field that has been understudied up until relatively very recently in the history of science. Dr. Marion, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really fascinating. I appreciate your taking the time. Thank you for having me.
以及跨语言对错误信息的易感性。我们有跨语言的如此多的信息。我们有这么多有趣的项目，工作量足够做一辈子，甚至更多辈子。我认为这是一个在科学史上直到相对最近才被研究不足的领域。马里恩博士，我想感谢你今天加入我。这真的非常引人入胜。我很感激你抽出时间。谢谢你邀请我。
I really enjoy talking to you and I enjoy talking about these issues. And I hope that people who speak two or more languages and even those who don't enjoy the conversation we have and want to dig in deeper and look at some of the studies, read the book, and find out more about the relationship between language and thought. And let's all go out there and learn a new language. Absolutely. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeckycology.org or on Apple, spot, or on Apple, spot, YouTube or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyenne.
我真的很喜欢和你交谈，我也喜欢谈论这些问题。我希望那些说两种或多种语言的人，甚至那些不说的人，都能享受我们进行的对话，并希望深入挖掘，看看一些研究，读读这本书，找出更多关于语言和思想之间关系的知识。让我们都去学习一门新语言吧。当然。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以通过 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 给我们发电子邮件。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Condayan。
Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是 Kim Mills。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。